Speaker 1: The eggman called the voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P and said, you know,
we cater to delusions all the time. Republicans
keep talking about catering to delusions when
it comes to trends. But what about the fact
that all these Republicans are constantly
catering to delusions from Christianity when
it comes to making law in the United States?
The ag man says it much more eloquently than I do.
Speaker 5: Tulsi Gabbard two Kayleigh MCENANY also
said that catering to the delusions of the trans
people is just bad politics because it's such a
small population. If there were delusions,
she's absolutely correct, Dave. However,
catering to the delusions of the Christian
slash Catholic God believers is good politics.
Ask Trump. Shalom.
Speaker 1: Right.
Right. Yeah. No. There is a double standard.
And we know that there is a double standard
when it comes to. Well, you know, Corinthians
and John and Paul, they say the following about
poverty or abortion or gay marriage. And we should
be taken seriously when in a civil government
proceeding, we invoke our scripture. To influence
what the law should be. Take us seriously. Well,
but a lot of people don't believe that. You could
you could say that that is a religious delusion of
yours that you're imposing on everybody else and
saying, listen to me. Go by what I believe based
on the supposed sacred nature of the text that
I'm probably misunderstanding anyway. But then
when it comes to trends, then they have a very
different perspective. The man is absolutely
correct. I have very little to add. We have
a fantastic bonus show for you today. We will
talk about Paul Gosar facing questions over a
staffer's alleged far right links. We will talk
about the new IRS free e-filing system that the
tax prep giants are furious about. And vice media,
once worth more than $5 billion, has filed for
bankruptcy. The latest in the media downfall that
is afflicting many BuzzFeed News and others.
All of it on today's bonus show. Sign up at
join Pacman dot com. You'll get instant
access otherwise. I'll see you back here.